Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday. It's punishment Tuesday.
Henry... remember how you came up with this really gross meal for me?
[Henry] Slobber carrots with me drool, and gross barbecue with me drool.
Gross barbecue with me drool, gross slobber carrots with me drool... and hat.
[Henry] Not with you!
No, *you*. You- your drool.
[Henry] Yeah.
Hm. I would prefer my drool.
[Henry] Why?
My drool's already in my mouth.
Couple questions, Henry. First off, what are slobber carrots?
[Henry] They are cooked carrots.
Okay, that doesn't sound too bad.
And then barbecue's basically just meat and barbecue sauce, right?
[Henry] Yes.
I mean, I gotta say.
So far, the only gross part of this sounds like it's gonna be your drool.
[Henry] Here's the luncheon loaf!
...Uh, oh.
[John] Henry, what do you think luncheon loaf is gonna taste like?
[Henry] You know, like goo!
They're so focused on value they didn't even
spend the money to print the "e" in value!
Okay, so we're making slobber carrots.
First thing you need to do is preheat the oven.
Henry! What temperature should we preheat the oven to?
[Henry] Four, two... five!
425! Sounds good.
I wonder if Mom helped you out with that.
We're gonna take out the salt and pepper.
Henry, do you wanna be Mr. Salt, or Mr. Pepper?
[Henry] Mr. Salt!
Okay.
[John] These are becoming... fairly well-seasoned slobber carrots here, buddy.
Okay, I think that's definitely enough.
Henry, do you wanna go ahead and drool on the carrots now,
or after they're cooked?
[Henry] Now!
[Henry blows raspberries]
Oh... that's...
[Henry] What's a luncheon loaf?
[John] It's a meat-like product.
And then it should just... OH!
Oh, God, that looks horrible.
[grunts loudly]
[Henry] That has to be superhuman strength!
BRRRRR!
[John] It just looks delicious.
Do you wanna know something interesting, Henry?
[Henry] What?
[John] The first ingredient of Valu Time Luncheon Loaf
is mechanically separated chicken, comma, pork.
[Henry] Pork...?
[John] And then the last ingredient... is smoke flavoring.
I didn't know that was an ingredient!
[Sarah] How does it smell, Henry?
[Henry] Just... eewie!
So, what you wanna do now is you wanna
cut a couple slices of Valu Time luncheon loaf.
I am *not* looking forward to having that in my body.
You wanna cook it over a low heat, aaand...
Also, it's time to put in the slobber carrots.
Alright!
Oh... we need a hat!
Henry, what should we make a hat out of?
[Henry] Cabbage!
Cabbage? That's a great idea!
So, Henry, when you're making a cabbage hat,
the key is to let Mom cut the cabbage.
[Sarah] We're also cooking coleslaw.
So, here's my cabbage hat.
Oh, yeah.
Alright, you ready for my cabbage hat trick?
[Henry] Yeah.
Whoa! [Henry laughs]
Whoa! [Henry giggles]
Aw, I did it!
So, once your luncheon loaf is reasonably browned, you put it on a plate of its own.
[John] Alright, Henry, it's time to put on the barbecue sauce!
Isn't that enough?
...Oh.
Oh, my.
And, of course, the last ingredient you need iiis... drool.
[Henry blows raspberries]
[John] Oh, just a tiny little sprinkling of drool.
Lastly, you're going to want to take your slobber carrots out of the oven.
We're ready to eat.
So, you take the cabbage hat... whoop! Bam.
Then, you take your barbecue with Valu Time Luncheon Loaf...
Oh, that is... that looks delicious.
[Henry] No, it doesn't.
[John] Aaand, on top go the slobber carrots.
[Henry] This is gonna be the grossest meal!
First, I'm gonna try the slobber carrots with drool.
It's actually quite good.
If anything, the drool *adds* something.
Gross barbecue with drool... okay.
[Baby Alice coos offscreen]
[gags]
[mouth full] It's so bad...
[fork clatters]
[John] Uuugh...
So much worse than a blenderized Happy Meal.
[loud sigh]
[Sarah] What about hat?
...Alright, I'll have a little bit of hat.
That's okay.
Oh... not very good.
[Sarah] Oh? [Alice coos]
So, there you have it, Hank, that was my punishment meal.
Uh... I don't recommend it.
It was, to quote Henry, the grossest meal ever.
I'll see you on Friday.